[Musica]
questa è la storia di una curiosa
fotografia una fotografia che ci sembra
di conoscere già che ci sembra di avere
già visto che sembra facile
immedesimarci dentro la foto mostra 29
uomini in posa quasi tutti i fisici 17
erano o sarebbero diventati dei premi
nobel ma poi quando prendiamo in mano la
nostra fotografia e la guardiamo bene
sembra che tra le dita un po ci sfugga
che attorno al cuore bianco e semplice
di questa fotografia che è quello lo
sappiamo ci siano delle zone grigie che
sembrano appartenere ad un passato
lontano se guardiamo bene le facce di
queste persone in posa riconosciamo
subito einstein la cui immagine più
famosa di qualsiasi altra icona pop ed
ace che vara madonna
riconosciamo marie curie perché l'unica
donna e se vi dico che sia appena messo
la gelatina in testa poco prima dello
scatto riconoscerete anche heisenberg
oppure anche se non ha il suo gatto
riconoscerete anche c reitinger perché è
l'unico con un doppio petto dellino
leggero un buffissimo papillon ed i
simpaticissimi occhialini tondi che
guarda da tutt'altra parte
se ne fregava cherel edinger nella
fotografia e più importanti sono tutti
verso destra alla sinistra o dietro
einstein chi ha fatto questa fotografia
sembra quasi conoscesse la regola
secondo cui l'attenzione delle persone
cade sempre verso destra sia che siano
due pagine di un quotidiano l'attenzione
va sulla destra e lo sanno bene i
venditori degli spazi pubblicitari sia
che sia una foto orizzontale si guarda
sempre chi sta a destra
chi ha fatto questa fotografia si chiama
benjamin cupri era un fotografo era
l'unico che poteva avvicinare i fisici
del ventesimo secolo e che poteva
parlare con loro durante questi ritrovi
a bruxelles
l'altra persona dietro alla macchina
fotografica si chiama ernest solvay era
un ricco industriale aveva tanti soldi
solvay voleva mettere a disposizione
dell'umanità
aveva anche un amico prediletto si
chiamava alfred nobel
anche lui ricco anche lui industriale i
due si sentivano spesso la sera
volevano creare qualcosa di imperituro e
così ho uno ha deciso di arrivare dopo e
di premiare le idee le scoperte le
trovate che avrebbero segnato per sempre
la storia del mondo l'altro ha deciso di
arrivare prima
per incentivare il nascere delle idee
delle scoperte delle trovate e crearono
e creò a questi ritrovi di fisici a
bruxelles i congressi solvay
dal 1911 in avanti ogni tre anni lui
morirà nel 1922 ne vedrà soltanto tre
saranno i suoi successori a portarli
avanti che vanno avanti e tuttora anche
oggi
ma torniamo alla nostra fotografia cosa
racconta scali dell'istituto solvay leo
paul park m schumann a una manciata di
metri oggi c'è il parlamento europeo
ma allora il giorno che è stata scattata
la nostra fotografia non esisteva ancora
il giorno che è stata scattata la nostra
foto e un sabato l'ultimo sabato di
ottobre il 29 per la precisione lawton
in belgio arriva presto i gradoni sono
già ricoperte di foglie tutti portavano
abiti pesanti tutti di buon taglio
qualcuno nascondeva un ombrello altri un
cappello le previsioni dicevano pioggia
se ci fosse stato un fotografo anche
dentro il portone prima di uscire sulle
scale che danno sul parco magari un
pubblicitario che deve fare un depliant
sui grandi saloni rinascimentali del
centro europa oppure un cronista belga
che vuole raccontare il fermento
culturale della capitale
beh questo nuovo fotografo avrebbe
fermato il tempo l'immagine di una
grande sala quadrata piena di gente con
molte chiacchiere instancabili
chiacchiere pure qualche scherzo
infantile tra i presenti
malgrado quello che si può pensare
guardando le facce di pietra che nella
foto che li ritrae veramente in un
salone molto ampio senza che nessuno
dica cosa fare o che diriga le
discussioni le persone riunite in un
gruppo si lasciano andare
c'è chi continua dirigente a parlare
dell'argomento serio per più è stato
convocato
chi non ci pensa più inizia a rilassarsi
con passatempi comuni che cerca di farsi
conoscere da chi anziani e più potenti
dal gruppo soprattutto se il motivo di
questo incontro e contribuire al
dibattito agli studi da fisico del
ventesimo secolo
gli anni più belli più magici della
storia della scienza
se ci fosse stato un fotografo anche
dentro il portone prima di uscire sulle
scale che danno sul parco non avrebbe
fotografato le sensazioni e di pensieri
ma noi saremmo riusciti a capirli della
nuova fotografia perché per capire il
carattere di ciascuno dei presenti
attribuirli
alcune caratteristiche personali lontano
dai manuali di fisica o da come ci hanno
insegnato la fisica nelle scuole è
necessario renderli umani vivi se la
fisica fosse insegnata partendo da
questa fotografia il passaparola di
quant'è bella correrebbe veloce al vero
boom nelle iscrizione universitaria
sarebbe per facoltà scientifiche ma
torniamo alla nostra foto cos'altro dice
freddo un freddo tagliente che va
peggiorando come sa esserci nel nord
europa soprattutto in centro soprattutto
in un parco ma di quasi tutti sono
abituati quasi tutti vengono da nazioni
poco lontane marie curie e il principe
dei brogli vengono da parigi einstein
bourne e planck vengono dalla germania
giraldin gare paoli vengono dall austria
niels bohr arriva addirittura da
copenaghen
siamo nel 1927 questo è il quinto
ritrovo di fisici di fama mondiale
in quegli anni fisici e non riuscivano a
mettere insieme un argomento comune che
descrivesse la parte più piccola della
materia a tono indivisibile un continuum
infinitamente indivisibile non
riuscivano neanche a mettere insieme le
equazioni di newton con quelle di
maxwell fisica classica con
l'elettromagnetismo ma poi venne il
momento di due grandi intuizioni due
grandi trovati che fecero capire tante
cose
una era la radiazione del corpo nero
l'altra era l'effetto fotoelettrico una
dovuta planck l'altra ad einstein ma noi
per la relatività lo sappiamo il padre
uno solo e albert einstein per la fisica
quantistica no i padri sono tutti e 29
questi uomini presenti a bruxelles sul
finire ad ottobre del 1927 ma non vi
dovete preoccupare la fisica quantistica
non vi deve fare paura ce l'avete di già
nelle mani tutti i giorni quando usati e
telefonini quando usate i cd lettori dvd
quando fate una tac oppure qua fuori
vengono i televisori a quanto un dott.sa
punti quantici quando si parla di fisica
quantistica si entra in un territorio
incantato come quello delle favole
oppure dei sogni un territorio dove in
realtà e finzione si mescolano e come
per le favole o per il sogno per la
fisica quantistica la strada da seguire
per capire come è nata come si sviluppa
la storia non è certo facile non è
immediata stavamo dicendo ai bivio l'ha
creato
blanc bianca non era il più bravo è clan
che era semplicemente il più rapido il
primo davvero avuto un'idea diversa
ecco voi dovete immaginare la comunità
scientifica
ecco immaginate mele esattamente come ve
la state immaginando adesso era
comodamente adagiata seduta rassegnata
sulla rassicurante fisica classica e
loro dicevano la fisica classica spiega
già tutto il clan che se ne esce con
questa sua trovata e dice il corpo nero
emette radiazione intanto che cos'è il
corpo nero
i fisici utilizzano spesso dei corpi che
non esistono al limite con una certa
densità una certa temperatura per poi
generalizzare e arrivare a oggetti di
uso comune dice il corpo niero il corpo
con buon il corpo nero con buona
approssimazione può essere può essere
visualizzato come il sole il corpo nero
un corpo che soprattutto la radiazione
incidente senza ma rifletterla quindi
per il teorema di conservazione
dell'energia deve re irradiarla e
congelare irradia dice blanc
secondo la formula è uguale a canu così
dice bianca lo prendono per matto è
certo è più facile prendere armato uno
che dice una cosa ma cosa stai dicendo
clan l'energia del corpo nero è uguale a
h
e un numero freghiamocene per noi la
frequenza è uguale a crois que 6,63
perché c'erano 34 già per secondo è
uguale a canu dice no ma sei pazzo
c'è però una persona che l'ascolta e
dice no prende la forma di planck se la
metti in tasca e cerca di capirla meglio
questa persona e albert einstein albert
einstein lo chiameremo il lupo solitario
e lui da solo nella sua stanza si mette
a studiare meglio la formula vita cosa
voleva dire planca dicendo questa cosa e
ne fa un'altra ipotesi ain se ne dice
supponiamo che la luce viaggi sotto
forma di quanti di energia oggi noti con
il nome di fotoni e studiamo la così
anche lui lo prendono per mano
perché la luce non si propaga sotto
forma di particelle non si propaga sotto
forma di quanti di energia nella fisica
classica è la comunità scientifica non
riusciva a credere che stava nascendo
questo bivio dove due spingere con e poi
sono diventati tre perché c'è una terza
persona che tende le orecchie a quello
che dice einstein
lo chiameremo l'uomo ossessionato questa
persona viene addirittura dal nord lo
scienziato che viene dal nord a
copenaghen arriva niels bohr miei sport
era il più grande studioso dell'atomo il
non plus ultra fuoriclasse assoluto il
crac dell'infinitamente piccolo e niels
bohr studiava il vecchio e polveroso
atomo di rutter for the un nucleo
centrale dense attorno degli elettroni e
dice no e l'energia degli atomi stessa
ad essere quantizzata e gli elettroni
non sono liberi di star dove vogliono ma
possono stare solo su certe orbite dette
discrete così diceva labor poteva dirlo
a casa sua a copenaghen guardando la
neve correndo con le renne e invece cosa
fa
crea la scuola di copenaghen dove
andranno a studiare tutti i giovani
talentuosi del ventesimo secolo tutti
andranno da lui a studiare
c'è chi dirà di lui lo dirà l'uomo alla
destra di einstein coi baffi all'insù
pollai ven dirà lisboa pare abbia fatto
il lavaggio del cervello a un'intera
generazione di fisici
e sì perché lui era un talebano e rhone
oltranzista della diffusione del
pensiero voleva che tutti la pensassero
come come decideva lui è così lindt
ottenere a tutti i giovani andranno da
noi tutti è andranno dire heisenberg
paoli ed è in questo momento della
storia della fisica che la scena la
prende paoli lo chiameremo il critico
l'uomo con il lato oscuro nella foto sta
guardando quello che sta facendo qualcun
altro nella foto già si capisce tutto il
carattere di questi personaggi paroli
cosa dice non tutti gli elettroni che
vogliamo possono stare sulle orbite ma
soltanto un certo numero soltanto un
certo numero di elettroni
grazie a questo contributo anni sboro
spiega lo spettro atomico degli elementi
rosso arancione giallo verde blu
esattamente il colore con cui vediamo
l'arcobaleno i colori dell'arcobaleno
ognuno con la sua frequenza ognuno con
la sua energia ma da quando le storie
sono belle lo sappiamo ci mettono un
attimo ad oltrepassare i confini
ed è proprio in questo momento che alle
orecchie questa storia arriva un
francese e francesi aristocratico sarà
per noi sarà luis de broin ad ascoltare
tutto questo a tirare fuori una nuova
pensato lui ci farà proprio la sua tesi
di dottorato su questi argomenti il
padrino sarà l'uomo alla destra di heinz
koll baffi all'insù pollán jemen e louis
de broglie dirà ma scusate einstein
parla di luce che si propaga sotto forma
di particelle io parlo di elettroni che
si propagano sotto forma di onde quindi
siamo davanti a una magnifica simmetria
della natura a questo momento della
storia della fisica la scena la prende
un americano arthur compton
lui fa esperimenti con i raggi ics e
proprio da un esperimento con i raggi lo
dimostra l'esistenza dei fotoni e ha
vinto il premio nobel proprio nel 1927 e
con queste credenze con queste piccole
sicurezze quelle che sapete anche voi
adesso questi uomini si incontra una
bruxelles sul finire ad ottobre del 1927
e discuteranno discuteranno
continueranno a parlare adesso questa
storia dobbiamo chiudere perché abbiamo
poco tempo avremo tempo in altri luoghi
di continuare le vicende di questi
personaggi che sono stati insieme una
settimana ma vi faccio un piccolo
spoiler ecco durante questa settimana
che sono insieme ci sono due teste là
dentro in questo gruppo e che creeranno
la fisica quantistica questi erano
uomini coraggiosi hanno creato la fisica
quantistica andando contro le credenze
di tutti ma singolarmente come succede
sempre da soli con le loro tesi e senza
l'appoggio di nessuno hanno creato
qualcosa che non c'era
bene in questo gruppo c'erano due teste
così grandi che ogni volta che venivano
messe nella stessa stanza
le due teste non così grande che non ci
stavano e litigavano continuamente
queste due persone erano albert einstein
e niels bohr tutte le volte che einstein
parlava niese board non capiva più
niente doveva andare lì contro che era
ossessionato da albert einstein e lui
miei sport quindi questa strada nuova
che stavano creando addirittura avrà due
strade parallele quella basata sul
concetto di probabilità creata dalla
scuola di niels bohr a copenaghen ed a
tutti i suoi scaltri
allievi in cui la fisica quantistica si
basa sul concetto di probabilità non
esiste la realtà in assenza di misure
dirà ai sali andrà al sangue al cervello
ogni volta che sentirà parlare di di
probabilità infatti gli dirà la famosa
frase dio non gioca a dadi
io direi proprio a bruxelles a bruxelles
sul finire ad ottobre del 1927 lo
spoiler è questa il duello tra i due lo
perderà albert einstein lo perderà
albert einstein e niels bohr vincerà mai
se indicherà la resa sventolando il
fazzoletto bianco con un'eleganza
incredibile gli dirò a salutandola la
stazione dopo la settimana che sono
stati insieme io non gioca a dadi ma
qualche volta può fare un'eccezione e
niels bohr a vincerà ma come in tutte le
guerre intellettuali o no se uno vince
una battaglia deve sempre aspettarsi la
contro mossa dell'avversario e la
contromossa di hansen arriverà arriverà
è come già a bruxelles risponderà alla
teoria ortodossa della fisica
quantistica quell appoggiata sul
concetto di probabilità albertanza
risponderà e creerà un esperimento
mentale della doppia fenditura a quelli
il bordeaux vrà a rispondere i giochi si
chiuderanno e saper hanno più avanti a
metà degli anni trenta con il paradosso
di ansie podolski rosen a cui farà
seguito il paradosso mentale del gatto
di schroedinger a quelli smog dovrà
rispondere i giochi si chiuderà nel si
apriranno ancora più avanti a metà degli
anni settanta con le disuguaglianze di
belle elint andremo in quantistico
ma questa è un'altra storia
[Musica]